هل انا الاوان لكي تكشف عن بعض الاسماء
التي لم تذكرها في كتابك بخصوص بعض
المقربين القيادات المقربه من الرئيس التي
كانت تمنع او تحجب عنه وصول بعض المعلومات
من مسؤولين عرب
فيها وسطات ومبادرات ومعلومات مهمه كانت
لربما انقذت العراق والعراقيين
التقيته يعني اغلب الوزراء او القيادات
العليا في الدوله في المعتقل وخارج
المعتقل ايضا بعد خروجهم كانوا يرمون يعني
بالحجه انه الرئيس ما كان يسمع كل شيء
والرئيس حرم من يعني كل المعلومات اللي
كان يجب ان يسمعها من القيادات العسكريه
عن وضع عمليه الدفاع حجم القوات العسكريه
الفرق الشاسع او الهائل بين عدم تكافل
القوتين بين القوات الامريكيه والقوات
العراقيه حسب ما هم نقلوا لي يعني سمعت
منهم انه كان الرئيس يفترض ان يسمعها
الرئيس في احد
اللقاءات حدثته
عن واقع معين حصلت
نفى علما بهذه الحادثه فاتذكر يعني بالحرف
الواحد قال اني يعني اي حادثه حادثه معينه
صارت يعني معينه حادثه
شخص مسؤول كان بالدوله العراقيه وتم سجنه
فاثار هذا الموضوع حفيظه لدى عشيرته
وقبيلته فنفى علمه بها واكد لي انه يعني
اني مو كل شيء ادري به
يسجن في ظل نظام صدام حسين والرئيس لا
يعلم كان قيادي من موسجن كان قيادي من
المستوى المتوسط
فنفع علمه به فاكد لي انه انا ما ادري
يعني كل شيء اني يوصلني اي موضوع معين
اعالجه على طول وذكر لي حاله معينه
بالبصره قال كان كانت قضيه معروضه على
القضاء وكان احد المسؤولين الكبار يتوسط
للاحراف
منحى
القضيه قال فاتنتين بالوزير وزير العدل
وطلبت من عنده ان يحضر جلسه المحاكمه
قالوا واخذت النتيجه
هؤلاء هذه التعيينات كانت يعني منه هو
الذي كان يعين هؤلاء المسؤولين الكبار
وبالتالي يعني هناك معلومات تتحدث عن حجم
معلومات عنه بتلك الاهميه هل يمكن ان نعرف
طيب انت لا تريد ان تذكر اسماء ولكن كيف
تصف هاتين الشخصيتين يعني اغلبهم
توفاهم الله يعني بصيغه او اخرى فما اريد
ان ندخل اقرب المقربين الى الرئيس احدهم
الى اقرب المقربين نعم وه كانت خيانه هذا
ما سمعته اني يعني اني ما كنت بالدوله هذا
ما سمعته من الوزراء ومن قاد عسكريين انه
كان بدنا ان نقول للرئيس عن بعض التفاصيل
اللي ممكن قد يستفاد من الرئيس لكن كنا
ننصح انه ما نقول لشيء من باب عدم ازعاج
الرئيس او عدم يعني
انت يعني فهمت منهم انه كان لهذه لهائتين
الشخصيتين مارب اخرى اهداف اخرى غير موضوع
ازعاج الرئيس والى ما هنالك لم يذكروا
ماذا سمعت منه عن لقائه بعزه الدوري نائب
رئيس مجلس قياده الثوره قبل الغزو كان
يلتقي بشكل طبيعي يعني يلتقي بالقياده
ويلتقي المرحوم مقصد اللقب اللقب قبل
الغزو بس انه بعد الغزو بعد الغزو التقى
وياه مره واحده
ومعهم قياده اخر في محافظه صلاح الدين
في مكان يعني
في مكان يعني مو بعيد عن يعني
شو بسيط عن المكان اللي القي القبض عليه
وكان معهم قياده اخر
ليس بعيدا عن المكان الذي قد كان الموعد
اللقاء بعد المغرب يعني
بعد العشاء
ما الذي دار في هذا اللقاء يعني على ما
تحدثان اعتقد على التنظيم المقاومه عمليات
تنظيم المقاومه والمتابعتها
واستطاعا ان يظلها على تواصل نعم عن طريق
المرافقين بس تقول انه قبل اعتقاله مباشره
لا بعد بعد اعتقاله العفو قبل اعتقال
الاول والاخير
يعني قبل اعتقال قبل اعتقال الراحل صدام
حسين بقليل جدا كيف ظل التواصل يعني وهو
في المعتقل لا وتواصلوا قبل الاعتقال وبقع
التواصل يعني مع التوجيهات توصل
للمرحوم عزه ابراهيم
سواء اللي التقطها عن طريق المحاكمات
مباشره او عن طريق المحامين